[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce premier numéro de la
nouvelle émission littéraire de Public
Sénat au bonheur des livres ce soir
pendant une demi-heure nous allons nous
intéresser à des femmes hors du commun
hors du commun pour le meilleur et pour
le pire et nous allons le faire avec
deux écrivains ou deux écrivains je sais
plus très bien comment on dit
féliciter un zog bonsoir félicité
vous publiez une brève libération aux
éditions stocks vous étiez entrer en
littérature de manière tonitruente il y
a une dizaine d'années en déboulonnant
la statue de votre père Maurice Herzog
célèbre alpiniste héros de la napurna et
là pour cette rentrée littéraire vous
faites de votre mère l'héroïne de votre
récit de manière d'ailleurs très
élogieuse
en revanche vos grands-parents en
prennent pour leur grade ça va pas
améliorer vos repas de famille mais on
va y revenir et puis Monica Sabolo
bonsoir Monica bonsoir vous publiez la
vie clandestine aux éditions Gallimard
c'est votre septième ouvrage vous avez
été couronné de nombreux prix mais
celui-là est d'une manière un peu
différente il est en rupture avec vous
précédentes publications ne serait-ce
que par le sujet auquel vous êtes
intéressé vous avez essayé de sonder le
rein les reins et le cœur du groupe
Action directe et notamment de deux de
ces protagonistes Nathalie Menigon et
Joël Aubron
rappelez-nous d'abord en quelques mots
ce qui était action directe pour ceux
qui ne s'en souviennent pas alors action
directe était un groupe
uscule d'extrême gauche qui est assez
vie entre 1979 et 1987 en France et qui
était un corpuscule de luthar armée et
qui au départ a commis des attentats
symboliques contre les représentations
de l'impérialisme et du capitalisme et
qui va glisser
vers le meurtre
c'est ça et donc ils ont ils ont commis
80 attentats ils ont assassiné deux
policiers dont un de 29 ans un ingénieur
général de l'armement et puis Georges
Besse personnage estimable emmables
prototype de la méritocratie française
fils du peuple qui était devenu le
président
d'une société nationale une grande
société nationale Renault et qu'est-ce
qui vous a fait vous intéresser à ces
personnages que d'aucuns peuvent
considérer comme des assassins bien sûr
je
je me suis bernée en réalité parce que
je voulais écrire une histoire je me
souviens sur un fait réel et créer une
histoire un peu facile ce qui est
vraiment le contraire de ce qui m'est
arrivé dans cette aventure mais je crois
qu'à l'origine j'ai vraiment été happé
par le fait que ce soit deux jeunes
femmes qui est assassiné Georges Besse
donc Joël Aubron 27 ans Nathali Menigon
29 ans qui attendent un grand patron un
soir de novembre 86 sur un banc pour
l'abattre ça me semblait totalement
insensé et elle me paraissait très jeune
et je me disais mais comment on
arrive-t-on là que chercher tel voilà
j'avais je sais je ne savais pas à
l'origine pour quelle raison mais
j'avais besoin de comprendre qui elles
étaient alors la grande réussite je
trouve l'une des grandes réussites de
votre livre c'est que on est troublé
enfin vous vous arrivez par votre
écriture qui est à la fois précise et
lacunaire
à nous troubler parce que vous éprouvez
des sentiments ambivalents à l'égard de
vos personnages fait d'une part de
réprobation bien sûr mais d'autre part
tout de même de sympathie d'empathie de
compassion et ça ça trouble votre
lecteur mais j'imagine que ça vous
trouble aussi ça a été c'est vrai que
j'ai écrit ce livre dans un état de
tension permanent et je crois qu'à
l'origine j'avais vraiment besoin de de
tracer une ligne nette entre le bien et
le mal je voulais aussi les mettre face
à leurs responsabilités parce que en 40
ans aucun membre d'action direct ne
semblait avoir émis le moindre regret ou
remords et cela faisait écho sans que je
le comprenne tout de suite au fait que
mon père lui n'avait jamais demandé
pardon pour ce qu'il m'avait fait dans
mon enfance
et effectivement en m'approchant les
choses deviennent plus complexes bien
entendu que la mort d'un homme en
assassinat c'est atteint des pas de
sable c'est un indicible un
injustifiable mais j'ai aussi
découvert une humanité j'ai vu des
choses j'ai vu que des êtres qui étaient
capables d'une grande violence pouvait
aussi être capable de d'humanité de
solidarité qu'à l'origine il voulait
changer le monde pour un monde plus
juste vous avez évoqué votre père très
important parce que c'est l'autre
élément de votre livre en fait votre
livre trace deux portraits en parallèle
celui d'action direct et celui de votre
père votre père qui n'est pas votre père
biologique mais qui vous a reconnu
quasiment à votre naissance qui vous a
élevé que vous appelez votre père et on
s'aperçoit que ce père est un être
extrêmement troublant lui aussi parce
qu'il vous a agressé quand vous étiez
jeune fille sexuellement et il n'a
jamais comme vous venez de le dire comme
les gens d'action direct exprimés ni
remords ni repentir ni demander pardon
et je me suis demandé quel était le
parallèle entre ces deux pourquoi vous
aviez tissé ces deux fils et au fond une
hypothèse que je vous soumets c'est que
à l'égard de ce père aussi vous éprouvez
des sentiments ambivalents c'est c'est
il y a les monstres entre guillemets
d'action directe mais ce père il y a ce
monstre entre guillemets qui est votre
père et avec à l'égard à son égard aussi
vous avez un mélange de sentiments
contradictoires c'est très juste
je pense que c'est la grande complexité
quand on a souffert d'inceste c'est
justement de démêler tout ça
l'aspect victime et bourreau qui se
mélangent en vous vous croyez que vous
êtes responsable même encore aujourd'hui
quand j'en parle quand je l'évoque j'ai
un sentiment de culpabilité de quelque
chose comme si j'avais commis quelque
chose de de mal que de parler était
grave mais il est à la fois ce père qui
était aussi un père et aimant par
ailleurs et qui avait et surtout que
j'aimais en tant que petite fille comme
on aime son père comme on aime ses
parents
et en effet c'est la complexité du cœur
de l'homme de voir qu'il peut y avoir de
l'ombre et de la lumière en une même
personne c'est très inconfortable c'est
très inconfortable et en même temps moi
la démarche de ce livre consistait à
être dans une sincérité absolue parce
que comme j'étais complètement perdue
que le livre a pris la main j'avais pas
du tout l'intention d'écrire sur ma
famille etc finalement ma colonne
vertébrale c'était ça c'était d'aller
chercher la vérité d'une façon furieuse
et la vérité parfois elle est complexe
et il y a plusieurs vérités qui se qui
s'infirment mais qui se recouvre je me
suis dit d'ailleurs que c'était le sens
de votre titre la vie clandestine parce
qu'on peut croire que la vie clandestine
c'est la vie clandestine d'action
directe ou celle de votre Père qui est à
la fois haut fonctionnaire et escroc
mais est-ce qu'au fond la vie qui
clandestine ce n'est pas cette vie qui
ont destine on nous la vie intérieure en
nous de sentiment trouble à l'égard du
mal nous avons en nous une un rapport
qui n'est pas toujours de réprobation à
l'égard du mal et c'est en chacun
d'entre nous je pense que on a un
sentiment de réprobation à l'égard du
mal mais on a des passagers clandestins
en nous on a des boîtes noires des lieux
où il y a nos chagrins notre
traumatismes mais peut-être non rage et
peut-être aussi des aspects parfois plus
sombres de nous c'est vrai mais moi ce
qui était important pour moi c'était
justement d'essayer de remettre les
choses à leur place d'être de voir là où
il y avait la lumière là où il y avait
l'ombre et même si ça se mêle essayer
d'être dans quelque chose qui est de
l'ordre de la clarté de réponse je pense
que je cherchais des réponses sans
savoir quelle était la question et
c'était j'étais lancé comme une flèche
vers la vérité
merci beaucoup Monica Monica Sabolo la
vie clandestine chez Gallimard
alors féliciter Herzog vous aucune
ambivalence des sentiments à l'égard de
vos grands-parents vous les condamnez et
on les condamne avec vous
si je peux me permettre dans mon premier
livre un héros je ne déboulonnais pas la
statue de mon père je remettais les
choses à leur place et ce livre portait
essentiellement sur mon frère donc acte
contact là on est dans les années 40
votre mère sort de l'adolescence à la 16
ou 17 ans ce sont les années
d'occupation d'abord de libération
ensuite et elle n'est
dans un milieu ça son père et le
descendant de la famille aristocratique
française la plus titrée et sa mère et
la descendante de la famille
industrielle la plus riche les chenêtres
les maîtres de forges du Creusot
décrivez-nous un peu ce milieu dans le
décrivez d'ailleurs au début du livre
dans lequel votre mère naît et dans
laquelle son adolescence se déploie
alors c'est l'histoire donc de ma mère
qui aujourd'hui à 96 ans et dont on
raconte pour la première fois son sa
grande histoire d'amour et son
affranchissement et donc elle s'appelle
Marie-Pierre et elle vit de 15 ans à 20
ans dans un hôtel particulier cours
Albert 1er qui est superbe
et qui ou se côtoient à tout le gratin
de la collaboration française
sous la houlette d'auto-abeth qui
organisait les choses en fonction de la
grande bourgeoise française c'est la
grande aristoc aussi française elle est
pétainiste et pendant que la France est
occupée on fait la fête dans votre dans
la famille de votre pari sous
l'Occupation bien sûr il y a ceux qui
ont résisté il y a ceux qui sont très
rapidement pour chasser mais dans
l'ensemble les beaucoup de Parisiens
s'ennuient parce que il y a le
couvre-feu le confinement on a vécu un
confinement très très éphémère il faut
imaginer des Parisiens qui vivent quatre
années de confinement et c'est vrai
qu'il y a Drieu La Rochelle la
ralettique au cochonel Emmanuel Berle
tous ces gens se retrouvent autour de
mai qui est la meilleure amie de José
Laval la fille du président du conseil
et dans ce milieu enfin contre ce milieu
votre mère se révolte d'abord elle elle
devient elle fait elle étudie la
philosophie les débuts de
l'existentialisme elle couche avec un
ami de ses parents bien plus âgé qu'elle
et puis elle fait capoter les projets
brillants de mariage avec Jean
d'Ormesson ou avec le prince Rainier
racontez-nous le mariage du prince
Regnier parce que la scène est-il à
alors elle est présentée comme on dit
puisque il faut se souvenir qu'à
l'époque une jeune fille à 20 ans 21 ans
devait être marié parce qu'il y avait
pas de contraception parce que une jeune
fille de la bonne société ne faisait pas
d'études et ne travaillez pas donc elle
sa seule destinée c'est d'être bien
marié donc on la présente au prince
Rainier de Monaco lors d'un déjeuner
chez les chez des un économiste
distingué et là elle se conduit de
manière un peu particulière alors j'ai
je l'ai quand même pas mal romancé mais
en gros elle n'a aucunement l'intention
de sacrifier ses études à un mariage
mondain et elle arrive en bleu de
travail elle met les doigts dans son
assiette mais le plus drôle c'est que
une fois que ce dîner a passé le
lendemain le prince Régnier lui envoie
un mot pour lui dire je ne suis pas dupe
et je vous trouve charmante alors le
sommet de sa révolte c'est quand elle
tombe amoureuse d'un jeune homme qui a
apparemment tout pour plaire il est le
fils d'un distinguer professeur de
médecine il est le Simon il est il
s'appelle Simon Nord il est le plus bel
homme de sa génération il est le plus
intelligent de sa génération il est
promis un brillant à venir et d'ailleurs
c'est ce qui va se produire il est un
jeune inspecteur des finances et en plus
par rapport à cette famille plutôt
collabo il est auréolé de la gloire
d'être un héros de la résistance mais
cependant la famille de votre mère se
dresse violemment contre lui parce que
péché mineur il est plus ou moins
communiste mais surtout surtout il est
juif c'est absolument ça la c'est une
tempête qui va se déchaîner sur ces ce
jeune homme de 23 ans 24 ans et cette
jeune fille jeune femme de 20 ans au nom
d'un antisémitisme qui est absolument
virulent il faut comprendre que pendant
la guerre la famille les parents de
Marie-Pierre sont des militants
vichistes on est vraiment au cœur de la
Révolution nationale il milite pour les
rafles pour la déportation des Juifs il
faut vraiment regarder les choses de
manière très lucide même si c'est dure
ils ne sont pas un peu collabo ils sont
simplement dans la machine et il
s'aligne sur sur ses objectifs vous
faites
épouvantable le votre grand-mère et la
maîtresse officielle de Paul Morand vous
faites un portrait de lui atroce alors
je n'ai pas en fait j'ai pas à inventer
quoi que ce soit parce que j'ai eu accès
à des inédits donc au journal de guerre
de Paul Morand qui donc a été lamant de
mai la mère de Marie-Pierre pendant
presque 20 ans et qui raconte ses
échanges avec elle en disant mais
Marie-Pierre qui est le plus beau parti
de France ne peut pas épouser un petit
juifont révolutionnaire et les termes
qu'il emploie je n'ai pas pu les citer
une extenso mais je l'ai j'en fais des
scènes j'en fais des dialogues ça sort
de leur bouche c'est pas moi qui les ai
inventés
merveilleux ou d'ailleurs épouvanta mais
la lettre du Père de Simon Nora les
lettres de Simon nord des lettres de
votre mère Marie-Pierre et puis une
lettre de votre univers qui répond à la
demande de mariage et qui dit nous ne
sommes pas du même village
c'est cette famille là elle est
franchement pas fréquentable je crois
qu'on se rend pas compte qu'à l'époque
même après le retour des déportés des
camps en 1945 il y a encore des familles
et des milieux qui sont ouvertement
antisémites malgré tout ce qui s'est
passé et évidemment pour eux c'est
absolument un casus belli leur fille ne
peut pas épouser un juif même s'il était
richissime mais votre mère tient bon
tiens bon sa famille l'enlève sa famille
la séance fermée la drogue la fait
enfermée dans une clinique psychiatrique
et si mon aura vient la l'enlever et il
se marie cette scène est extrêmement
romantique au milieu du Vercors parmi
ses camarades de maquis elle tient bon
quel est le ressort extraordinaire de
votre mère qu'est-ce qui fait que elle
résiste à ce milieu qui pourtant lui lui
offre bien des avantages
je pense son tempérament et puis aussi
son affranchissement intellectuel c'est
une intellectuelle d'ailleurs elle m'a
passé son journal donc je peux voir à
travers ces les années à quel point elle
étudie elle lit de l'histoire de la
philo elle est très atypique et elle
sale ça lui donne des armes en fait
intellectuelles pour se révolter et
aussi à l'époque où on était élevé par
des gouvernantes et je pense qu'elle
s'est construite une sorte de système de
défense intérieur très très jeune qui la
protège qui l'insularise qu'il a lui
donne de la chlordestinité et qui lui
permettent de s'affranchir et elle dit
très clairement dans dans et ça ce sont
ces mots elle dit on se détache de tout
on se détache des siens c'est triste
mais il faut savoir se détacher ce qui
est extraordinairement courageux vous
lui avez elle a 96 ans vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure vous lui avez fait lire
si mon aura malheureusement n'est plus
là mais vous lui avez fait lire ce livre
qu'elle a été sa réaction
vous montrer que vous faisiez de ses
parents elle était elle a eu accès au
manuscrit je lui ai proposé de l'amander
elle était très très heureuse du
résultat elle se retrouve complètement
dedans et elle a elle l'a confirmé
d'ailleurs dans des entretiens dans la
presse c'était tout à fait ça mais il
faut comprendre Daniel event que pendant
près de 80 ans tout a été mis sous le
tapis dans cette famille mais dans cet
univers social on ne parlait jamais de
cette période et au fond ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que récemment les
archives s'ouvrent il y a beaucoup de
d'historiographie je pense au livre de
Laurent Joly sur la rafle du veldive et
donc des correspondances se font jour
des journaux comme celui de Paul Morand
apparaissent un de plus et donc il y a
matière et nous sommes et je me sens
responsable de transmettre cette mémoire
c'est pour ça que j'ai écrit ce livre je
l'ai écrit pour ma mère pour choisi mon
aura auquel ce livre est dédié qui est
un grand modèle d'inspiration mais aussi
parce que si d'autres génération ne fait
pas ce travail de mémoire personne ne le
fera
bon franchement quand on a lu une brève
libération de félicité Herzog on a envie
de chanter la carmagnole et on se dit
qu'on n'a pas fait la révolution de 1789
pour rien parce que le milieu que vous
décrivez
ne fait pas envie la réprobation qu'il
suscite est quand même assez
considérable l'idée qu'il a dominé la
société n'est pas très rassurant il faut
voir c'est un une aristocratie qui vit
dans un entre soi depuis l'affaire
Dreyfus antidéreyfussart mais il faut
aussi savoir que chez Brissac il y a
aussi des conseils brissacs qui ont
résisté et qui ont été arrêtés par la
Gestapo comme quoi dans les familles
c'est très complexe voilà
Monica l'idée que
il faille rendre public des choses qui
étaient secrètes et qui pesaient sur la
vie intérieure ça fait écho aussi à ceux
qui vous a guidé dans votre livre
je comprends tellement bien ce que
félicité et cette sensation aussi quand
on écrit ce genre de livre de se dire
mais dans quel guêpier je me suis fourré
pourquoi je vais là c'est quoi
j'avançais et je suis persuadée que
féliciter se disait la même chose
pourquoi parce qu'il y a voilà de mettre
à jour ce qui était dans l'ombre depuis
toujours oui c'est une nécessité pour
les pour mes enfants également mais mais
ça
oui ça crée quand même des un
remue-ménage intérieur assez puissant
alors le bonheur des livres c'est
d'abord le plaisir de ses lecteurs et
donc nous avons interrogé l'une d'entre
elles Jeanne Seignolle qui va nous
expliquer pourquoi elle aime les livres
et qui va vous poser une question je
crois que c'est à VOUS Monica qu'elle la
pose Jeanne on vous écoute
[Musique]
je m'appelle Jeanne j'ai 26 ans et
j'adore la littérature si quelqu'un m'a
donné le virus je pense que c'est
surtout ma maman qui avait beaucoup de
livres à la maison et où quand on était
petit il y avait toujours des livres
partout et avec mes frères et sœurs elle
adorait nous lire notre petite histoire
du soir et ce que j'aime beaucoup lire
moi c'est les romans la littérature
contemporaine plutôt anglophone ça c'est
les restes de ma licence d'anglais et
aussi les romans graphiques
l'un de mes gros coup de coeur
dernièrement que j'ai lu c'est un roman
graphique qui s'appelle les contraceptés
qui écrit par deux journalistes
Guillaume Dodin et Stéphane Jourdain et
en fait dans ce livre on va beaucoup
parler de contraception masculine et
donc il y a des moments justement très
informatifs mais aussi assez drôle ou
par exemple ils vont rencontrer des
personnes qui font des slips chauffants
et donc on va se retrouver on a
l'impression d'être dans une sorte de
mafia ou en fait il y a plein d'hommes
qui se retrouvent dans une salle pour
coudre leur slip chauffant donc c'est
vraiment très amusant et on en apprend
quand même aussi beaucoup sur ce sujet
dont on parle pas suffisamment à mon
goût la question que j'avais pour vous
Monica Sabolo c'est est-ce qu'il y a un
bon moment pour publier un livre c'est
quelque chose qui qui m'a frappé dès les
premières pages vous parlez d'un sujet
qui est très intime et compliqué à
aborder c'est la question de l'inceste
je trouve que vous le faites très
justement et est-ce que justement vous
vous aviez besoin de temps avant de
pouvoir en parler et aussi peut-être de
faire votre deuil pour que ce soit un
sujet dont vous puissiez parler dans
l'un de vos livres merci Jeanne alors
Monica est-ce qu'il y a un moment pour
publier ah oui c'est sûr mais il y a un
moment pour écrire aussi c'est-à-dire
que moi tous mes livres vont à chaque
fois un petit peu plus loin et peuvent
se rapprocher de cela de ces mots qui
sont si difficiles à poser donc au
départ c'était de ligne et puis à
travers la fiction et en effet je pense
que c'est un chemin de vie un chemin
aussi bien existentiel que littéraire
donc je pouvais le faire là mais jamais
j'aurais pu le faire avant ne serait-ce
qui est qui a trois ans quand j'ai sorti
le précédent
voilà cette émission tout ça touche à sa
fin pardon mais avant de nous quitter
le moment est venu de faire des
recommandations de lecture de donner nos
coups de cœur et on va commencer par
vous féliciter Monica mais attention
c'est satisfait ou remboursé votre
recommandation les lecteurs enfin les
ceux qui nous écoutent doivent adorer ce
que vous allez leur proposer Monica quel
est votre recommandation alors je
recommande le trésorier payeur de
Yannick Hennel que un livre magnifique
sur la charité sur l'amour les phrases
sont tellement belles donc je pense que
personne pourra demander à te rembourser
très bien le Trésorier Payeur Yannick
Hennel et félicité votre livre de la
semaine la petite menteuse de Pascal
Robert Diard qui est un petit non même
un coup de poing et qui tire parti de la
connaissance évidemment de Pascal
robertière du monde judiciaire et qui
retrace toutes les ambiguïtés d'une
adolescente face à une des une agression
sexuelle très bien
elle crée en effet elle montre en effet
la difficulté qu'on a à connaître la
vérité la nécessité d'écouter d'un côté
mais la nécessité aussi de creuser pour
chercher quelle est la vérité alors mes
coups de cœur à moi c'est Yasmina raisin
grande écrivain français et c'est son
dernier livre grand roman mais dans un
petit format en poche donc accessible à
tous
Monika je vous l'offre
[Musique]
Sarah jolienne Fardel sa préférée je ne
l'ai pas lu je le confesse on m'a dit
que c'était un très beau premier roman
des difficultés de vie dans le monde
rural mais je l'ai choisi surtout à
cause de son éditrice Sabine vespiser
car c'est une petite maison indépendante
par les temps qui courent ce n'est pas
si fréquent une petite maison
indépendante d'édition et de grandes
qualités rares sont les ouvrages qu'elle
publie et qui ne sont pas intéressants
féliciter je vous le donne
ça c'est un ouvrage à la fois classique
et pourtant finalement pas très connu en
France de Charles Dickens de grandes
espérances c'est une nouvelle traduction
on connaît bien David copperfeed mais
c'est le pendant de David Copperfield
très très connu dans le monde
anglo-saxon pas très connu en France
très beau livre sur
[Musique]
les orphelins et la vie des orphelins la
pauvreté l'accomplissement soit enfin
bref les thèmes de Dickens je vous
l'offre à vous et celui-là
Georges Perec lieu j'aurais pu vous
l'offrir par souci d'égalité mais je
vais le garder malheureusement ou plutôt
heureusement pour moi Georges Perec est
un immense écrivain et en plus un
écrivain complètement atypique donc
toutes les œuvres sont
extraordinairement originales par leur
façon d'aborder le réel et là c'est un
projet qu'il n'a pas pu achever parce
qu'il est mort avant qui était un
journal des lieux qui lui parlait
étrange comme donc c'est une série
d'annotations anecdotique de détails au
contraire général de photos
de documents autour des lieux qui lui
parlent et tout à coup en feuilleté
feuilleton ce livre on est transporté
dans les lieux on rencontre la même
nostalgie que la sienne alors que ce
sont des lieux qu'on ne connaît pas ou
qui ne nous parlaient pas à l'origine
c'est assez incroyable et comme je n'ai
pas fini de le feuilleter je vais
continuer je vais me précipiter pour
l'acheter en plus il est pas si cher
alors qu'il évolue lumineux voilà merci
à vous tous Merci à VOUS Monika Sabolo
la victoire destine chez Gallimard merci
à vous féliciter un zog une brève
libération chez Stock merci à Jeanne
seniol merci à vous tous qui nous avait
suivi vous pouvez nous revoir sur le
site de Public Sénat ou bien en podcast
sur la vos plateformes préférées et puis
nous nous retrouvons la semaine
prochaine
même jour même heure même chaîne à moins
que d'ici là nous ne nous soyons croisés
dans une librairie bonsoir et merci
[Musique]